>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Good morning.
I am Carla at Library
of Congress and I want
to welcome you to this
very special story time
at the library.
I love reading, don't you?
It is so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We are excited and have teamed
up with Ms. Ms. Dolly
Parton's Imagination Library
to introduce you to
some wonderful authors
who will share their
stories with us.
This partnership works
through her imagination Library
and it is awe-inspiring.
She and her team have given
away over 100 million books
to help encourage young readers
to read across the world.
Here at the Library of
Congress we share that passion
for developing young readers
and we know that the best way
to encourage people like you
to read is to make reading fun
so that is what we will do.
I hope you enjoy
today's story time.
Even more, I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun.
Today we will warm up by singing
some songs, touching your toes,
and then get comfortable and
get ready to here stories.
Now let's get started!
Good morning!
Good morning and
welcome to the library
of congress' fifth imagination
story time coming to you
from the beautiful pavilion and
today we have a special guest.
My name is Caroline and I come
from the young reader's center
and today we are welcoming
Melissa from the music division
who is going to read
and play her flute.
Melissa Wertheimer, I
should say her last name.
So we are going to start
with our good morning
song, our hello, friends.
We are going to sing and sign to
the tune of good night ladies.
So the sign for hello is the
salute, just a little salute
and the sign for friends is
you take your two index fingers
and you hug them one way and
then the other way, and the some
for time is do you tap your
imaginary watch and the sign
for to say is you
touch your mouth.
Okay? So hello, friends.
Hello, friends three times.
It is time to say hello.
Hello, friend, hello,
friend, hello, friend,
it's time to say hello.
Good job. [Applause] All
right so since we are going
to be reading about trains I
thought we should start off
with a little song
that everybody knows --
down by the station, down by the
station early in the morning,
see the little puffer
bellies all in a row.
See the little engine driver
pull the little lever, puff,
puff, toot, toot, here we go.
What is a puffer belly?
The designers called it
puffing Billy because all
of the steam it created.
So here we go --
down by the station,
early in the morning See the
little puffer bellies all
in a row See the engine driver
pull the little lever Puff,
puff, toot, toot, off we
go Down by the station,
early in the morning, see
the little puffer bellies all
in a row See the engine driver
pulled a little lever, Puff,
puff, toot, toot, off we go!
[Applause] So now we are going
to do a little action rhyme
and we are going to make
our arms into the wheels
that go chugging
down the tracks.
Can you get your arms bent?
And then we are going to
move them in a circle.
Okay. This is choo-choo train.
Here is a little choo-choo
train puffing down the tracks,
now now it is, leaned forward,
and now it is going back.
Leaned back.
Now the bell is ringing,
ding, ding,
now the whistle blows,
toot, toot.
What a lot of noise it makes
(Cover your ears) Everywhere
it goes.
One more time.
Here is a little choo-choo
train coming down the tracks.
Now it is going forward,
and now it is going back.
Now the bell is ringing, ding,
ding Now the whistle blows,
toot, toot What a lot of noise
it makes everywhere it goes!
(Applause) Good job!
So miss Melissa is going
to read the classic 19 book
by Waddy Piper and
illustrated by Gerald
and Anne Houseman called
what do you think --
the little engine that could.
Our theme today is called
persistence or perseverance.
What does that mean?
It means sticking with something
no matter how hard it gets
and not giving us -- okay?
The little engine
that could. »
: Good morning, everybody.
I have a special job
for everybody out here.
Your job is when ever hear
the sound, toot, toot,
do you hear that sound?
Your job is to make
the train go.
We have to do our action
from our action rhyme.
And we try that one more time?
This is the sound and you
have to make the train go.
Toot, toot.
So this is the little
engine that could.
Toot, toot The little train
rumbled over the tracks.
She was a happy little
train because she had
such a jolly load to carry
Her cars were filled full
of good things for boys and
girls There were toy animals,
giraffes with long necks.
There were teddy bears
with almost no necks at all
and even a baby elephant.
Everybody be an elephant.
We have a baby elephant
on the train.
And then there were dolls, dolls
with blue eyes and yellow curls.
Dolls with brown eyes
and brown bobbed heads
and the funniest toy
clown you ever saw
And there were cars full of toy
engines and airplanes, tops,
Jack Nieves, picture
puzzles, books, and every kind
of thing a boy or
girl could want.
But that was not all --
some of the cars were filled
with all sorts of good
things for boys and girls
to eat Big gold oranges
and red-cheek apples,
bottles of creamy milk for
their breakfast, fresh spinach
for their dinners, and lollipops
for after dinner treats The
little train was carrying all
of these wonderful things to
the good little boys and girls
on the other side
of the mountain.
She puffed along merrily --
toot, toot And then all of a
sudden she stopped with a jerk.
She simply could
not go another inch.
She tried and she
tried toot, toot,
but her wheels would
not turn What were all
of those good little boys
and girls on the other side
of the mountain going to do with
the wonderful toys to play with
and the good food to eat?
Here comes a shiny new
engine -- toot, toot toot --
said the funny little clown
that jumped out of the train.
Let us ask him to help us.
So all of the dolls and toys
cried out together, "Please,
shiny new engine, won't
you please pull our train
over the mountain?
Our engine has broken down
and the boys and girls
on the other side won't have any
toys to play with or good food
to eat unless you help us!
But the shiny new
engine snorted.
"I pull you?
I am a passenger engine.
I have just carried a fine,
big train over the mountain
with more cars then
you ever dreamed of!
My train has sleeping cars with
comfortable births, a dining car
where waiters brings whatever
hungry people want to eat
and parlor cars in which
people sit and big soft tears
and looked out of place windows.
I pulled the likes of you?
Indeed not!
" And off he seemed to the
Roundhouse where engines live
when they are not busy Toot,
toot House sad the little
train and toys all felt.
Then the little clown
called out,
"The passenger engine is not
the only one in the world.
Here is another engine coming,
a great big, strong one.
Let us ask him to help us!
" Toot, toot The little
toy clown waved his flag
and the big strong
engine came to a stop.
"Please, oh, please big
engine, cried all the dolls
and toys together, won't
you please pull our train
over the mountain?
Are engine has broken down and
the good little boys and girls
on the other side won't have any
toys to play with or good food
to eat unless you help us.
"But the big strong engine
bellowed, "I am a freight train.
I had just pulled
a big train loaded
with big machines
over the mountains.
These machines print
books and newspapers
for grown-ups to read.
I am a very important
engine indeed.
I won't pull the likes of you."
And the freight train
puffed off indignantly
to the Roundhouse Toot,
toot . Toot, toot.
Toot, toot The little
trains and all
of the dolls was very, very sad.
And now that we are all
sad and we feel defeated,
let's take a little break
for a happy song it is
called the railroad waltz
and it is a dance.
And railroads are special
because we count to three.
In everybody count to three?
123 123 all right.
If you would like to dance,
here is a railroad waltz.
We will get happy a little bit
because that way we will not be
so sad (Flute playing)
(Applause)
>> Beautiful.
Does everybody feel
a little happier?
I hope so.
So now we get back to our story
where the little train and all
of the dolls were very sad.
"Cheer up, cried the
little toy clown,
this right engine is not
the only one in the world.
Here comes another."
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot He looked
very old and tired,
but our train is so little.
So perhaps he can help us.
So the little toy
clown waved his flag
and the rusty old engine
stopped . "Please, kind engine,
cried all of the dolls
and toys together,
won't you please pull our
train over the mountain?
Our engine has broken down
and the boys and girls
on the other side won't have any
toys to play with or good food
to eat unless you help us.
" But the rusty old engine
side, "I am so tired,
I must rest my weary wheels.
I cannot pull even
so little A-Train
as yours over the mountain.
I cannot. I cannot.
I cannot. " And off he rumbled
to the Roundhouse, chugging.
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot I cannot.
I cannot. I cannot.
Then indeed the little train
was very sad and the dolls
and toys were ready to cry.
But the little clown called out,
"Here's another engine coming,
a little blue engine,
a very little one
but maybe she will help us.
" Toot, toot.
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot The very little
engine came chug, chug,
chugging merrily along when
she saw the toy clown's flag,
she stopped quickly.
"What is the matter, my
friends, she asked kindly.
" "A little blue engine,
cried the dolls and toys,
will you pull us
over the mountain?
Our engine has broken down
and the good boys and girls
on the other side won't have any
toys to play with or good food
to eat unless you help us.
Please, please help
us, little blue engine.
" "I am not very big, said
the little blue engine.
They use me only for
certain trains in the yard.
I have never been
over the mountain.
" "But we must get over the
mountain before the children
awake, said all of
the dolls and toys."
And the very little engine
looked up and she saw the tears
in the dolls' eyes and she
thought of the good little boys
and girls on the other
side of the mountain
who would not have any toys or
good food unless she helped.
Then she said, ""I
Think I Can....
I Think I Can....I Think I Can
and she hitched herself
to the little train.
She chugged and she pulled and
pulled and tugged, and slowly,
slowly they started off.
(Chugging, chugging) The toy
clown jumped aboard and all
of the dolls and toy
animals begin to smile
and cheer (Chugging,
chugging) Toot, toot Ding,
ding when the little
blue engine,
""I Think I Can....I Think I
Can....I Think I Can I Think I
Can....I Think I Can....I Think
I Can I Think I Can....I Think I
Can....I Think I Can.
" Up, up, up, faster, and faster
and faster the little engine
climbed until at last,
they reached the
top of the mountain.
Down in the valley lay the city.
" Hooray! " Hooray!, cried
the funny little clown
and all the dolls and toys.
The good little boys and girls
in the city will be happy
because you helped us,
kind little blue engine.
And the little blue engine
smiled and seemed to say
as she puffed steadily
down the mountain --
(Chugging, chugging) chugging).
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot (Chugging, chugging).
Toot, toot I thought I
could, I thought I could,
I thought I could,
I thought I could.
The end. (Applause)
How fabulous! »
: Thank you Ms. Melissa.
Okay. So let's do
an old classic,
"I have been working
on the railroad.
" We have been working
on the railroad, right?
So she is going to give us our
key (Flute playing) I had been
working on the railroad, all
the live day I have been working
on the railroad, just to pass
the time away Can you hear the
whistle blowing, rise
up so early in the morn.
Can't you hear the captain
shouting, Dinah blow your horn.
Dinah, won't you blow, Dinah,
won't you blow, oh, Dinah,
won't you blow your horn?
Dinah, won't you blow, Dinah,
won't you blow, oh, Dinah,
won't you blow your horn
Someone is in the kitchen
with Dinah Someone is in the
kitchen I know Is someone is
in the kitchen with Dinah,
Stremming on the old
banjo Fee-fi-fiddly-eye-oh
Fee-fi-fiddly-eye-oh
Fee-fi-fiddly-eye-oh Strumming
on the old banjo.
(Applause) Wonderful!
Great singing!
All right, so we have come
to the and of our livestream.
Let's sing our goodbye song,
which is the opposite
of the hello, song.
So we are going to wave
goodbye, friends, waved goodbye
to friends It is time
to say goodbye Goodbye,
friends Goodbye,
friends Goodbye friends,
it is time to say goodbye.
See you next month.
(Applause)
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.